how do you feel about a director also
editing their own film how do I feel
about director ending their own film
well if they're a good editor then why
not um I think it's it's funny I have to
felt like your friends who are both in
indie filmmakers who I look up to and
one of them is like always get it
outside editor always and the other ones
like never get an outside editor always
cut it yourself and these are two guys I
respect equally you know and they're
both friends with each other so I think
it just depends on your own skill level
if you know if you come up through
editing and you trust yourself as neder
that's great if you have no skills as an
editor either technically or creatively
then get outside editor you know for
sure um you know there's advantages to
both you know getting an outside editor
you have someone else you know you get
fresh eyes on the footage and a new
perspective and then you know but on the
other hand you know it then then you're
like no wait but let's do that let's do
that I want to get my hands in there and
then as a but if you're directing you
know if you're editing by yourself and
you've no perspective of anything else
but on the other hand you know your
footage you shot it you were there you
know I always say I'm on a set there's
you know there could be 50 100 people
there you know ninety-eight percent of
them are there to get the image on the
camera you know there's the
cinematographer the lighting people the
crew people the grips the costume the
Wardrobe the makeup the actors are there
to get the image on the camera but the
only people on set who are there from
the editorial department as your editor
is almost never there it's the director
and the script supervisor you know and
maybe your first ID or your or UDP has
some sense of hey wait a minute we're
crossing the line or do we get coverage
here there but they're focused on a lot
of other things too so I think it
behooves every director to know editing
because that's going to be you in the
Edit room and your editor is going to
look at you and go wait a minute why
didn't you shoot coverage of this or why
didn't you or how did you
salon or you know like basics of editing
so I I think which also means it
behooves you to have a lot of respect
for your script supervisor and pick a
good script supervisor who knows who
knows that stuff and I've been very
lucky on my films to have that and to
pay attention to that person so for me
what I've done actually with all my
films because I did get a good editing
background when I was at USC and it was
funny i remember a faculty advisor at
cinematographer very famous
cinematography was on the faculty then
like after my first year there and
you're trying to decide kind of do you
want it for the intermediate classes do
you want to sort of focus on
cinematography your editing or whatever
and he said what do you want to be and I
said direct I want to be director when I
grow up yes yeah let's break it and I
said he said what do you want to take he
said oh and take cinematography I love
those cameras you know it's very flashy
he said no no if you really want to be
director you'll take editing because
you're always gonna have a
cinematographer on set you know so you
know or even if you're the
cinematographer you're going to have a
gaffer you know to make it the lighting
look you know you're always going to
have someone else to help you on them on
the camera side so as I was I was lucky
to get that advice because I think
otherwise I would have gone into camera
and I still wouldn't know how to add it
so subsequent to that on every film i've
done i've always had another on the
features anyway I've always had someone
else edit them I've always had an editor
per se but I've also on all of them done
additional editing like doing seat
individual scenes or doing the polish at
the end or working literally
hand-in-hand with the editor and I think
that has been of that has worked well
with my filmmaking because I get the
advantage of both worlds i get an editor
who can come in with fresh eyes and say
what were you thinking cheating the shot
or this shop is so elaborate you need
you don't need it you know but at the
same time I can kind of say okay this is
my editing style you know and I want the
cuts to kind of be like this or the
pacing to be like this or this kind of
shot selection now you take it pass out
and likewise they'll cut a scene and
then I'll think it pass at polishing
that up
and that's been a lot of fun you know
I've had a lot of fun editing all my
films and they've all kind of work that
way one way or another you know with
between us the movie now I mean Dean
gonzalez who's an old friend of mine he
he cut the film he's the editor you know
worked on it for about four months but
then for about a two week period we had
a really intensive period where
literally my family left town went on
vacation without me which was hard to
get them to do that and Dean essentially
moved into my kitchen with his macbook
pro which is this and I had my laptop
which is this big and we would just sit
hand and had literally as each of us had
a hard drive he cut a scene in the
morning I would recut in the afternoon I
could have seen he recut you know and we
would eat a lot of pizza you know and
drink a lot of snapple iced tea because
they had we had a lot left over from
production and you know we basically
knock that thing into shape in two weeks
and we're both very happy with that you
know that it was essentially the first
cut there was still a lot more work
after that but it was like oh this is a
movie now like it's like we saw it it
really came together and I think he
appreciated what I did I certainly
appreciate what he had done and and it
worked well and even with my first movie
Omaha the movie poster there we we cut
that on the Paramount lot yeah which is
very nice they were because it was a we
told them it was a student film which
was but it was also an indie film you
know it was a future and they gave us
all the upright move they give us to
edit Suites on a paramount lot and for
free but the caveat was with all the
upright movie olas we could ask for so
for those who don't know these are
invented in 1930s and kind of phased out
in the 90s or early really phased out in
60s for editing when when flatbeds came
in but I had I kind of trained on one at
film school and then on a kickboxing
movie I'd worked with so said they had
all these things kind of in storage and
they said yeah you can use as many as
you want so I was like okay well I've
got an editor she's going to cut scenes
on one of these upright movie eliz I
have an assistant editor okay you cut
some scenes on here is I'm I'll take one
too and I start so I start cutting
scenes too and yeah so I was like this
is great you know that's the original
nonlinear
editing I mean these things still said
does he luan the side of them I mean
they're really from the 30s I mean that
was 50s but still they were they were
all but they work fine you know and that
was yeah forget about flatbeds we were
cut in old-school you know on the
Paramount lot you know which is a great
you know if you're gonna be cutting on a
movie I might as well be on a Hollywood
studio
you